[Music]
it's probably no surprise that Donald
Trump has been the subject of over 2100
CNN reports since he announced his
candidacy for president on June 16
okay maybe 2100 is a little bit
surprising but the basic calculus is
something I think everyone cynically
understands Trump gets ratings the news
carries Trump a little less obvious is
that Trump's high poll numbers are
actually a result of his outsize
coverage in the media political science
professor John sides has produced a
number of Handy graphs that show the
correlation between Trump's share of
coverage versus his poll numbers and is
pretty conclusive what's more if you
graph all the GOP candidates polling
numbers verse their share of coverage
you get a correlation of 0.96 it's close
to a straight line as I've ever seen of
course you could say causation moves the
other way here that whole numbers drive
coverage and in some way they do only
news coverage usually comes first people
hear a lot about a candidate research
that candidate identify in the same way
that you do when you hear a pop song on
the radio over and over and over again
and that exposure ultimately means
they're more likely to give that name to
pollsters the news then reports more on
the top candidates which means even more
coverage which means even higher polling
and it becomes a cycle that perpetuates
itself until the top dog makes a mistake
it's three agencies of government when I
get there that are gone commerce
education and the what's the third one
there let's say or a new fresh-faced
steal some attention away I think women
all over this country heard very clearly
what mr. Trump said the problem is that
Trump's mistakes are often so imply at
all
and news making that they work to his
advantage and new fresh faces are the
ones that Trump the tax the hardest if
you listen to her for more than five
minutes straight you get a headache 2100
news stories later and here we are we
know why the news works like this less
ratings mean less ad revenue means less
profit means lower stock prices means
fewer investors means layoffs fire in
America indeed in the global economy
everything always has to run the news
especially Cable News has a vague
interest in keeping its dependence on
capitalist incentives under wraps even
though everyone knows that ratings to a
large part determine the news news
organizations have to tout their
journalistic integrity even if it's only
a formality and this might just be the
gift that Donald Trump is giving to all
of us more than anything I can remember
the Trump phenomenon strips away the
false righteousness of the news media
when Trump does something outrageous CNN
doesn't cover it by choice but because
they are forced to do so the Trump
phenomenon strips away the false
righteousness of politicians too Trump
has co-opted political language and
employed it to such a ridiculous and
shameless degree that it's emptiness is
laid totally bare and lastly Trump
strips away the false righteousness of
us the American public the second GOP
debate was the highest-rated program in
the history of CNN CNN is forced to
cover Trump because we force them why
when we put on you know something with
Jeb Bush talking about the economy or
Scott Walker talking about labor unions
why doesn't anybody watch that it's in
our nature to gravitate toward
confirmation bias and sensationalism it
takes a force of will to consume media
that may be bored but crucial for making
intelligent political choices and in
large part it's a mental muscle that
most of us myself often included don't
want to exercise Donald Trump exists at
the Nexus of all these things and his
invocation of all three is a
an important lesson the news media
politicians and the general public are
all responsible for the existence of
Donald Trump and no one of these things
is going to change drastically overnight
but if all of them move just a little
bit in the right direction toward
integrity honesty and engagement
respectively the difference could be
substantial
we know that the news media is biased
and politicians talk and the
news and the politicians know we know it
still they go through the formalities it
is exactly formalities like this that
can keep a system alive longer than it
needs to be so maybe we meet someone
like Donald Trump to pull down that last
layer of credibility how are you gonna
create jobs in this country I'm just
gonna do it $50 on the patreon which is
$50 away from the big goal of $1,000 and
that starts to make this financially
feasible for me so if you like the nerd
writer this is something you don't think
you're seeing somewhere else on YouTube
or the internet pledge a little bit
money through the project and we can do
a lot of more stuff there's no more
stickers or mugs left but I want to
order some more swag maybe some more
mugs but I'd like to hear what you would
like of nerdwriter swag and that
universal let me know in the comments
and we'll get some and put them up thank
you so much for watching and I will see
you guys next Wednesday